un visitante sin invitación llama a la
puerta en busca de comida
no no no no no
mientras la gente mira ligeramente
desconcertada por la situación
sigue adelante tranquilamente dejando el
pueblo intacto
pero no siempre es así en tailandia este
elefante derribó parte de una pared para
entrar en la cocina
sí
o quizás puede ser peligroso lejos de
una cohabitación armoniosa entre los
elefantes y el hombre es desafiante a
veces otras letal
son pongan un s and nos lleva al lugar
donde fue atacado el año pasado cuando a
las 6 de la mañana un elefante cargó
contra él
golpeó aquí aquí y aquí
mi moto quedó destruida quedé
inconsciente durante varios minutos y
cuando me desperté estaba allí mirándome
tranquilamente y luego se fue son pan
como resultado del ataque pasó tres días
en el hospital
la red
estaba sangrando por todas partes mi
brazo aquí en mi espalda también mira a
mi hueso ya no está en el lugar correcto
al menos 20 personas murieron a manos de
elefantes en tailandia el año pasado y
hay víctimas mortales de ambos lados
gracias a los programas de conservación
su población aumenta un 8% cada año y se
calcula que su número total oscila entre
los 3.000 y los 4.000 ejemplares
mientras vagan en busca de comida a
veces se encuentran cara a cara con los
humanos
así que para intentar reducir el número
de incidentes un grupo de 200
voluntarios trabaja para mantenerlos
alejados de los asentamientos humanos
a la cabeza de la ong está na ni cuándo
en áfrica los elefantes mueren a causa
de la caza furtiva
pero aquí en asia mueren en conflictos
con los humanos
los electrocutan y los envenenan por
ejemplo
asustados o reclamando venganza por los
daños a sus cultivos
los humanos matan una docena de
elefantes cada año
a este le dispararon 15 veces
otro fue electrocutado por un cable
colocado estratégicamente para matar a
los elefantes intrusos
para evitar estas escaladas nani y su
equipo patrullan todas las noches las
afueras de los pueblos lugares en los
que los elefantes se suelen aventurarse
un residente les ha alertado de que hay
un elefante cerca
el agua janio chiles el 6 del iphone
sepa lo que le pase
y si yo hiciera
área
utilizan métodos menos dañinos gritando
y haciendo brillar su linterna para
tratar de hacerlo retroceder
[Música]
y
el elefante estaba junto a una casa del
pueblo
así que ahora que lo hemos encontrado y
como está tranquilo no parece agresivo
vamos a intentar empujarlo de vuelta al
bosque para que no se acerque de nuevo
puede ser peligroso puede ser muy
peligroso cuando lo veas en esa posición
podría darte la vuelta rápidamente y
cargar contra nosotros por eso siempre
mantenemos una distancia de seguridad
este aldeano que no forma parte de la
ong utiliza fuegos artificiales para
defenderse es una práctica habitual pero
la ong no la fomenta ya que podría hacer
que los elefantes se vuelvan violentos
les parece un método eficaz pero miren
podría desembocar en un accidente
es difícil para nosotros decir algo
realmente es su área pero ese es el tipo
de cosas que estamos tratando de cambiar
es una batalla difícil ya que la falta
de hábitat natural obliga a los
elefantes a adentrarse cada vez más a lo
desconocido